time now for final exam where we find
out for certain which of two foxnews
professionals has been paying more
attention at work he's been playing
video game our defending champion this
week
Carly Shimkus a reporter for fox news
headlines 24/7 she's being challenged by
Fox correspondent Peter Doocy a veteran
of that suit mixes awesome well we're
glad to have both of you back I lose
don't tell my bosses that I wasn't
paying attention
okay you know the rules will tell you
anyway hands on buzzers I ask the
questions the first one to buzz in gets
to answer you have to finish we have to
wait until I finish asking the question
in order to buzz in each correct answer
is worth the point a wrong answer
subtracts a point from your total best
of five wins are you ready ready okay
great question one a world leader
stripped down to his trunks to take a
refreshing and religious ice bath which
leader was it Peter Doocy it was
President Putin Vladimir Putin yes how
dare you use those words let's see if
you're right
roll tape Vladimir Putin has taken his
shirt off again why did you do this mr.
Vlad President Putin made his way to the
lake in a fur coat and fur boots and
then he stripped down to his bathing
trunks Peter Doocy clearly a Russian
agent you knew it was Vladimir Putin did
you know that - you probably I did and I
know that a bee Huntsman's father
ambassador Huntsman yes Russia also did
that as well
so half-point situation you know I'd
love to but the judges are saying that
we're gonna stick to the rules
sorry dad despite despite I've been
practicing former arm wrestling champ
question Jim Tendo thing once again a
cable news host we know that world well
just released a folk rock ballad he says
was inspired by the women's March which
Cable News host was it Oh Peter Doocy it
was morning Joe Scarborough are you sure
I've never seen the show I not my not my
I think it's Brian Kilmeade for the
record but whatever we're gonna find out
on the table
it's like when your boss comes in
wearing an ugly shirt you don't want to
be the one telling him it sucks a better
example when you're one of your most
Papa's talents Joe Scarborough thinks
he's a pop star may get the chance to
stand
[Music]
he's like 10 times worse than Nickelback
oh I didn't know they made the song like
a thing on the show okay that al
sharpton also cut in the album years ago
with James Brown little-known fact
I have it yeah you got that right Peter
Doocy thank you he's not killing me
question three I'm doing myself out
research and researchers in China just
announced a terrifying scientific
breakthrough
not surprisingly they say they've
successfully cloned which animals Carly
a monkey a monkey I actually don't know
the answer so we're gonna roll tape and
find out if it's a monkey and game close
a major breakthrough as Chinese
scientists clone monkeys for the first
time ever inching one step closer to
human cloning that's a big Curious
George fan I'm very dishonest monkey
yeah they all we've ever seen no that's
not gonna end well the chinese clone
monkeys thirty years from now this will
be seen as a turning point in the
history the species question for prior
to last Sunday's big football game
police in Philadelphia used which food
product on telephone poles to keep wild
Eagles fans from climbing them Carly
Crisco that's disgusting I don't believe
you oh let's go to the tape there you go
the cops in Philly actually greased the
poles with Crisco to try to keep people
from calming them after the game that is
a real thing that happened it didn't
really work Crisco Cobbs it's really
that you know and then it rains and then
there's just Crisco all over the
sidewalk is fill it's just and effect
yeah you're not low cal though that's
right okay so we're in a weird place so
we really find ourselves here we're in
sudden-death so each of you has to cage
match okay sorry this is the last
question are you both ready yes okay the
winner will emerge from this round a
dozen or so camel
were disqualified from a major camel
beauty pageant in Saudi Arabia not a
minor camel beauty pageant a major one
after judges discovered the animals had
been injected with what Peter Doocy HGH
HGH the human growth hormone human
growth whatever it's that would be a
very serious advantage for a camel no I
think the point is they don't want them
to look like people they want them look
even more camel like you know a lot of
why no we're gonna roll the tape and see
is it HGH
the country has camel beauty pageants
but there is we're sad to tell you
scandal in the world of camel beauty a
dozen animals have been disqualified
from a major contest after judges found
they had received Botox injections
apparently Botox can deceptively make a
camels head look bigger and its lips
droopier didn't you just say that you
didn't know anything about this yeah
yeah that was always nice to see who
watches our show Peter Doocy brave
effort but Carly shim kiss my man yes so
now look at that
two to one game over Carly you win
another I'm the coveted mouth-breathing
mug means even more and of course the
adulation of our many fans so
congratulations Peter Doocy oh that was
a valiant attempt thank you I'm gonna
just not tell anybody that I did the
quiz tonight so they don't want we can
share the mug thank you defeat okay pay
attention to the news each and every
week especially the weird parts so you
can tune in every Thursday to compete
against our contestants there's much
more in this show stay tuned
[Music]